لم تمضي عمليه دهم منتجع الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب من قبل عملاء مكتب
التحقيقات الفيدراليه اف بي اي دون عواقب
عنيفه واخرى تنظر بالعنف خلال الانتخابات
النصفيه
برصاص رجال الامن وعلى منصات التواصل
الاجتماعي زاد استخدام مصطلح الحرب
الاهليه اكثر من 10 اضعاف
المخاوف من احداث ناميه قبيله وخلال وبعد
الانتخابات النصفيه عزت بعد عمليه الدعم
وقد حذر الاف بي اي اخيرا من تعرض
العاملين في الانتخابات للعنف
2018 وقبيل الانتخابات النصفيه وقعت هجمات
خطيره للغايه وبعد انتخابات 2020 وقع
اقتحام الكونغرس في السادس من يناير بسبب
القلق الذي اعترضين حياله نتائج
الانتخابات ما ادى الى حدوث اعمال عنف اذا
اعتقدوا ان تم احتمالا كبيرا بوضوح اعمال
وعنفني الان
لكن ما الذي يغذي هذه المخاوف الامنيه
يرصد متخصصون زياده في نشاط الميليشيات
والمجموعات اليمنيه المسلحه المتطرفه
كما يلحظون ارتفاعا في مشاركه هذه
المجموعات في مظاهرات عنيفه
حاله يعززها الانقسام السياسي والايدلوجي
في الولايات المتحده فضلا عن استمرار
الدعاء ترامب والمرشحين المدعومين منه بان
الانتخابات الرئاسيه الاخيره كانت مزوره
سلطات الامريكيه اجراءات امنيه وقضائيه
لرجع اعمال العنفي فحاكمه اكثر من 900 شخص
ممن اقتحم الكونجرس غير ان استمرار الخطاب
الذي سبق احداث السادس من يناير عام 2000
و 2021 لا يساعدوا في تبديد المخاوف
الامنيه التي تحيطه بالانتخابات النصفيه
فدي منصور الجزيره واشنطن